Alam
alikum it was something 1988 some
Christian Missionary was passing from
some street so he was Distributing the
booklet so I told him that you believe
that Jesus is the god or Son of God I
told him he was the messenger of God he
was not uh the Son of God and the
prophet Muhammad sallam is the last
prophet after him no Prophet is going to
come so he said what makes you Muslim so
what should have been answered for that
brother ask the question while he was
passing from missionary in 1988 who were
Distributing booklets and he said that
Jesus Christ is a messenger of God not
God so he asked him what makes you a
Muslim that was a question so you what
is the reply that you should give see
Muslim is a person who submits to
almighty God by definition anyone who
submissible to almighty God is called a
Muslim and the fundamental
Creed of a Muslim is to give the
sh Muhammed that there's no God but
Allah and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him is the messenger of Allah this is
the basis but the basic definition of
Muslim is a person who submits will to
God you want to go to high level I
believe that there's no God but Allah
and Prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
is a messenger more details you have to
follow the Commandments of Allah subhana
tal you have to submit a will to Allah
and the will of Allah subhana tal is
given in the Quran and it says in the
Quran Allah the messenger and what a
beloved Prophet said so the basis of
Islam is the Quran and the authentic
Hadith of the prophet mallam in the
Quran it is mentioned that we should
believe in all the messengers that came
by name 25 are mentioned in the Quran so
amongst the 25 mentioned in the Quran
one of the name is isaam therefore we
can say that a Muslim is not a Muslim
until he believes in Jesus Christ peace
be upon him so it is one of the
requirements of a Muslim who has
knowledge of Islam that he should
believe that Prophet Jesus peace be upon
Him is a messenger of almighty God so
besides believing in Allah one and only
we should not associate partners with
him believing in the last and final
messenger mm Salli wasallam you have to
believe in all the messengers including
Prophet Jus peace be upon him and we can
further go and tell him that no musl
muslim until he believes in Jesus Christ
peace be upon him and tell him Islam is
the only non-Christian Faith which makes
it an Article of Faith to believe in
Jesus Christ peace be upon him we
believe that he was one of the mightiest
messenger of almighty God we believe
that he was the Messiah transed Christ
we believe that he was born miraculously
without any male intervention we believe
that he gave life to the Dead with God's
permission so the Muslim and the
Christians together but there are many
Christians like this Christian
Missionary who said that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him as God which we take
objection to and you can tell him there
is not a single unequivocal statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon him himself says that I am
God or he say worship me if anyone can
point out to me any unequivocal
statement any unambigous statement in
the complete Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon himself says that I am God
or where he says worship me I'm ready to
accept Christianity in fact if you read
the Bible it is the contrary Jesus
Christ peace be upon himself says it's
mentioned in the Gospel of John chapter
number 14 ver number 28 my father is
greater than I Gospel of John chapter
number 10 verse number 29 my father is
greater than all Gospel of Luke chapter
number 11 verse number 20 I with the
Finger of God cast out devil Gospel of
Matthew chapter number 12 verse number
28 I with the spirit of God cast out
Devils Gospel of John chapter number 5
verse number 30 I can of my own self do
nothing as i j i judge and my judgment
is just for I seek not my will but the
will of my father so Jesus Christ peace
be upon him said anyone who says that I
seek not my will the will of almighty
God is a Muslim so Jesus Christ pleas be
upon him a Muslim and it's clearly
mentioned the book of Acts chapter
number 2 verse number 22 that e man of
Israel listen to this Jesus of Nazareth
a man approved of God amongst You by
wonders and miracles and signs which God
did by him and you witness to it he men
of Israel Jesus of Nazareth a man
approved of God You by wonders and
miracles and signs which God did by him
and you witness to it so clearly mention
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him was
a messenger of God he was not God
himself he was a man and we believe that
he was one of the mightiest messengers
of almighty God hope that the question